what was the quote of the season for you
Oh everyone would say standing by
Monique Hart girls brown cows Scottish
the brown cows stunning stunning
stunning anything that came out of
Monique's mouth was my favorite quote no
shade no tea from these girls they're
living from me Oh mine what's done in
the dark America will be brought to the
light America Belle Ida's own actor
packs America I love that anytime
Monique heart says America because I
don't think she understands that the
whole world is watching America y'all
say offend me right now 1 2 3 thank you
it's the word on everyone's lips besides
of course the obvious which I'll let
everyone else say I think the quote that
everyone knows Vangie I mean she broke
the internet miss Angie the whole world
talking about her even if you're not
watching the show you know the words
miss Vangie I'm not gonna say myself
because I don't wanna be that [ __ ] be
that [ __ ] Vangie MS Benji Benji
[Music]
[Music]
quote of the season for you too big no
too vague so what has it won any
conversation someone start studying too
big and just cut them off too vain my
favorite quote is clearly proposed
because we are what okay
the court of this season which
unfortunately the fans don't get to see
is Queens walking anytime we're on set
and we're moving around they yell out
Queens walking that's like a trigger
moment rise
[Music]